[موسيقى]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم ابيكم تتخيلون
معاي انكم قمتوا من النوم كاي يوم عادي من
الايام واول ما فتحتوا باب البيت انصدمتوا
ان الجو كان وايد حلو والهوا نقي والسماء
صافيه اكيد قلتوا في بالكم اليوم لازم
نروح
كشته مهم ركبتوا السياره قررتوا انكم
تروحون السوبر ماركت وانتم في الطريق
تسوقون شفتوا على يمينكم وعلى يساركم كله
اشجار والمكان كله
اخضر انزين وصلتوا للمقر او السوبر ماركت
اللي تنزلون له وانتم هناك تتسوقون
اكتشفتوا ان كل منتجات رخيصه وفي متناول
اليد ولا وكلها مصنوعه في البلد المنشا
اكيد راح تتسائلون وين هالمكان وين
هالعالم الاخضر تخيلوا ان هذه راح تكون
قطر 20 30 انزين السؤال شلون شلون احنا
راح نحول بيئتنا قطر من بيئه صحراويه الى
بيئه خضراء الجواب جسم بسيط هو عن طريق
التخلص من النفايات انزين اكيد بتقولون
احنا ايش دخلنا في النفايات ليش لازم
نتخلص منها اصدمكم بمعلومه تدرون ان كل
فرد فينا في قطر ينتج حوالي 2 كيلوغرام من
النفايات في اليوم يعني بمعدل تقريبا 2
مليون طن سنويا تخيلوا لو ما احد فينا فكر
شلون تتخلص من ه النفايات وتخيلوا ان
ارضنا مليانه كلها نفايات شلون احنا راح
نعيش على هذه الارض انزين شلون اجيالنا
عيالنا عيال عيالنا شلون راح يقدرون
يعيشون في هذه
الارض الحل بتكنولوجيا او بكلمه سحريه
بسيطه الا وهي الانحلال الحراري وقبل لا
ابتدي اشرح هذه التكنولوجيا حابه اطرح
عليكم سؤال منو فيكم يحب الطبخ يرفع
يده اوكي مش الجميع خصوصا الاولاد طبعا
احنا في عصر التكنولوجيا شنو يعني عصر
التكنولوجيا يعني اي احد فينا يجوع يتصل
على طلب
الاكل عند باب البيت لكن اليوم ابيكم
تتخيلون انكم راح تطبخون معاي فاول شي راح
تسوونه تجيبون الجدر الضاغط وتحطون فيه
المقادير وتسكر عليه عدل وتتاكد انه ما في
داخله اكسجين وبعدين تشغلون النار وبعد
ساعه ساعتين تجهز عندكم الطبخه مبدا
التكنولوجيا اللي هي الانحلال الحراري
بالضبط نفس الشي شلون بدل ما نحط المقادير
والمكونات الغذائيه راح نستبدلها
بالنفايات
وراح تنتج عندنا الثلاث اشياء
اساسيه في قاع الجدر راح ينتج عندنا
السماد العضوي في المنتصف راح يكون عندنا
الزيت العضوي و في مقدمه الجدر راح يكون
عندنا الغاز العضوي انزين ليش احنا ننتج
غاز ليش ننتج زيت ما هي دوله قطر اساسا
غنيه بالبترول والنفط فاحنا ما نحتاج ه
التكنولوجيا صح لكن احنا بنحتاج السماد
العضوي زين ليش السماد العضوي شنو فوائد
السماد العضوي على السماد الصناعي اثبتت
الدراسات رقم واحد ان السماد العضوي يساعد
على احتباس الماء في التربه لما ن احتبس
الماء في التربه معناته ما راح تحتاجون
انكم تسقون الزرع ثلاث مرات في اليوم مره
واحده كفيله انها تكفي النبات الشيء
الثاني انتم ما راح تحتاجون ان انتم
تصنعون سماد صناعي لان السماد العضوي راح
يحتوي على مواد مفيده للتربه وللنبات
وخصوصا ان دوله قطر التربه مالتها شحيحه
فراح يساعد على نمو النبات بشكل اسرع
انتاج المحاصيل بشكل اكبر فراح نساعد ان
احنا نامن الامن الغذائي لدوله قطر وهي
الرؤيه رؤيتنا في 20
30 انزين شنو هي النفايات اللي احنا
استخدمناها ركزنا على اربع اشياء اساسيه
اول نوعين هم
البلاستيك نوع البلاستيك الاول هو بولي
اثلين عالي الكثافه والنوع الثاني بولي
ايثلين منخفض الكثافه زين تسالوني ليش
البلاستيك تخيلوا انكم من تقومون الصبح
لين تنامون انت في كل شي تهلكون فيه ترى
البلاستيك سواء كان ناحيه الاكل يعني لو
تطلبون اكل من ب مغلف بالبلاستيك تشترون
اغراض من الجمعيه مغلفه بالبلاستيك تطبخون
في البيت تشترون لحوم وخضره وفواكه بعد
مغلف بالبلاستيك زين مستحضرات التجميل
الصابون كل شي تستخدمونه تى مصنوع
بالبلاستيك ومن ه النوعين بالذات فبالتالي
احنا عندنا النفايات اللي راح تنتج بتكون
البلاستيك اكثر شي والنوعين الثانيين هما
نفايات عضويه اول شي عندنا نواه التمر ليش
نواه التمر ترى دوله قطر تعتبر السادسه في
انتاج التمور يعني اكيد راح تكون عندنا
نواه التمر متوفره وبعد فيها عناصر غذائيه
مفيده للتربه والنوع الاخير اللي هي فضلات
الحيوانات ركزنا على الجمال ليش لانه
موجوده في قطر خصوصا ان احنا نستخدم
الجمال في سباق الهجن وفي نستخدم اللحوم
والى
اخره انزين شنو هي المراحل
شلون راح نعالج النفايات راح نرسل شاحنات
بكل بساطه تضغط النفايات من مكان الانتاج
الى مكان المعالجه في مكان المعالجه راح
تخضع النفايات الى عمليه الانحلال الحراري
مثل ما شرحت وبعدين في الاخير راح ينتج
عندنا السماد وراح نغلفه راح نوديه
للاراضي الزراعيه للاستخدام
النهائي انزين شنو استنتجنا من هاي
الدراسه المكثفه اللي صارلنا الحين سنين
احنا ندرس فيها نج ثلاث اشياء اساسيه
اول شيء عشان يكون جوده السماد جدا مفيد
لازم يكون نسبه البلاستيك اعلى من
النفايات الاخرى زين ليش لان البلاستيك
يحتوي على الكربون وكل ما زادت نسبه
الكربون كل ما زادت احتباس الماء كل ما
كان جوده السماد افضل والشيء الثاني اللي
هو ان اكتشفنا انه عشان ننتج السماد وما
ننتج زيت ولا غاز اللي احنا مش محتاجينه
لازم نعالج النفايات بدرجه حراره منخفضه
والشيء الثالث والاهم هو احنا راح نقلل
الانبعاثات الكربونيه شلون مو احنا قلنا
بالبدايه ان لما نستخدم السماد ما راح
نحتاج نسق الزرع كثير يعني ما راح نحتاج
ماي كثير انزين الماي مصدره من وين في قطر
عن طريق المياه المحلاه والمياه المحلاه
تستهلك كميه كبيره من الطاقه خصوصا لما
نحرق الغاز
والبترول انزين هل هذه التقنيه مستدامه
انا الصراحه فكرت فيها يعني اكثر من مره
بس لنفرض ان خلص النفط وخلص الغاز ما صار
عندنا موجود شلون بنعالج النفايات هل هي
تكنولوجيا فعاله فاحنا فكرنا في استخدام
الطاقه الشمسيه اول شيء هي مفيده بيئيا ما
راح تطلق انبعاثات ولكن الشيء الوحيد فيها
هو انها مكلفه غاليه وخصوصا في الصيانه
والتركيب لكن مع تطور التكنولوجيا فاحنا
اكيد راح نوجد حلول لهذه الطاقه
الشمسيه والحين اي حد فيكم حاب يطلع على
هذه المعلومات ولا الشكل مفصل موجوده كلها
في المنشورات عن طريق جوجل
سكولر وتذكرون العالم اللي تكلمنا عنه
الحين في البدايه اي العالم الاخضر
النظيف تخيلوا لو كل واحد فينا فكر انه
يشوف ويفكر ويوجد حلول لثغرات ومشاكل
عندنا في المجتمع تاكدوا ان كلنا راح نوصل
لمستقبل اخضر مستدام في دوله قطر شكرا
لحسن
استماعكم